there is no one who doesn't know
obstacles in their life you know even
Bill Gates has obstacles he's got to
figure out how to keep all that money
why is it that so many people act like
animals why do they just react to what's
going on rather than the plan and
strategize because if you don't accept
excuses pretty soon people stop giving
them and they start looking for
solutions there's no such thing as
useless knowledge because you never know
what doors it's going to open for you
almost any accomplishment in the history
of the world has come at the hands of
people who have taken risks some people
hate spiders some people hate snakes
I hate at poverty I couldn't stand it if
you have an average brain you're capable
of almost anything be nice to people
because once figured over their
suspicions of why you're being I still
be nice to you real success involves
lifting up those around you here's a
retired American neurosurgeon and former
presidential candidate of the United
States he has authored numerous books on
his medical career and political stances
he was a director of pediatric
neurosurgery at the John Hopkins
Hospital in Maryland he's Ben Carson and
here is my take on his top ten rules for
success you know I'm reminded of a very
successful young businessman and he
loved to buy his mother these exotic
gifts for Mother's Day and he ran out of
ideals and then he ran across these
birds these birds were cool you know
they cost $5,000 apiece they could dance
they could sing they could talk he was
so excited he bought two of them sent
him to his mother couldn't wait the
color of her Mother's Day mother mother
what you think those birds and she said
they was good
they said no no no mother you didn't
need those parents those births cost
$5,000 apiece they could dance they can
sing they could talk and she said well
they should have said something and you
know that's where we end up - if we
don't speak up for what we believe there
is no one who doesn't know obstacles in
their life you know even Bill Gates his
obstacles he's got to figure out how to
keep all that money so you know
everybody's got problems and it really
is how you face those problems if you
allow it to be an insurmountable wall
then you become the victim and if you
say this is a piece of cake I'm finding
my way over under around or through this
obstacle one way or another and you gear
yourself to solutions and that's that's
always the answer
always be thinking about how I can do
something rather than why I can't do
something and so many people lead their
lives by reacting rather than by
thinking and really when you think about
why why do we have these incredibly
sophisticated brains with these big
frontal lobes because we're the only
creatures that God made with the ability
to extract information from the past and
the present and to project it into a
plan for the future so we don't have to
react you know animals you know this is
well whatever is happening they react -
right
why is it that so many people act like
animals why do they just react to what's
going on rather than the plan is
strategize we have the ability to figure
out where we want to be a year from now
five years from now ten years from now
and to begin to organize things in a way
in order to accomplish those goals and
when we don't do that
we place ourselves and tremendous
jeopardy because we place ourselves in
the situation where we can only react I
was
had a horrible temper poor self-esteem
all the things that you think would
preclude success but I had something
very important I had a mother who
believed in me and I had a mother who
would never allow herself to be a victim
no matter what happened never made
excuses and she never accepted an excuse
from us and if we ever came up with an
execution said do you have a brain and
if the answer was yes then she said then
you could have thought your way out of
it it doesn't matter with John or Susan
or Mary or anybody else did or said and
it was the most important thing she did
for my brother and myself because if you
don't accept excuses pretty soon people
stop giving them and they start looking
for solutions and that is a critical
issue when it comes to success I would
get on the bus and I would go downtown
to the Detroit Institute of Arts and
roam through those galleries until I
knew every painter who painted the
picture and when they were born and when
they died and what period it represented
and I was always listening to my
portable radio listening to classical
music and you know I'd be walking down
the streets of Detroit listening to
classical music and people thought I was
nuts this guy's crazy but years later
when I decided that I wanted to be a
neurosurgeon I want to go to the place
that's best known for neurosurgery net
would be Johns Hopkins but as I said
before they only took two people a year
out of a hundred 25 applicants but when
I got an interview and I went there the
fellow who was in charge of the
neurosurgery residency program George
beat her high was also in charge of
Cultural Affairs at the hospital
and somehow the conversation turned the
classical music and we talked for over
an hour about different composers and
their Styles conductors orchestras
orchestral halls there was no way he
wasn't taking me in the program because
he had to have somebody to discuss these
things with but what I emphasized to
young people all the time is there's no
such thing as useless knowledge because
you never know what doors it's going to
open for you and the more you know the
more options you have almost any
accomplishment in the history of the
world has come at the hands of people
who have taken risk people who are
willing to push the envelope people who
are willing to explore the unknown even
if you go and you look in the Bible you
know that the people that are held up as
a heroes they're not the ones who were
sitting in their tent under an olive
tree you know were people who are going
out there doing start and you know the
key thing about taking risk is learning
you know and if something doesn't work
out learn from it and then you're able
to move further we have to always
recognize that you know knowledge
frequently comes at a price you know
Thomas Edison said you know 999 ways
that a light bulb did not not work right
you know many of us are familiar with
the cleaning formula 409 why do they
call it that the first floor hundred
Nate didn't work you know but you know
you just put these things into
perspective and you learn from them
Walter dandy the great neurosurgeon at
Johns Hopkins many decades ago was the
first one to do operations on the
posterior fossa the back part of the
brain no one thought it could be done
first thirteen patients all died now can
you imagine how devastating that was I
can't even imagine what he said to the
14th patient when they see how the other
13 do you know but but the fact of the
matter is we now are able to do that
operation routinely and safely I did one
last week and so you know we just have
to put all these things in perspective
and recognize that we will never make
progress unless we're willing to take
risk but
we have to take them in an appropriate
fashion right because you know there
there's a large group of people who
never get anywhere because they're
afraid to take a risk there's another
group of people who never get anywhere
because they take too many of the wrong
dress
they're always getting knocked back into
the pond so that's where this tremendous
brain comes in where you are able to
analyze one of the things that I hated
was poverty you know some people hate
spiders some people hate snakes I hated
poverty I couldn't stand it and but you
know my mother couldn't stand the fact
that we were doing poorly in school and
she prayed and she asked God to give her
wisdom what could she do to get her
young sons to understand the importance
of developing their minds so that they
control their own lives and you know
what God gave her the wisdom at least in
her opinion my brother and I didn't
think it was that wise because it was a
turn off the TV let us watch only two or
three TV programs during the week with
all that spare time read two books a
piece from the Detroit Public Libraries
and submit to her written book reports
which she couldn't read but we didn't
know that
she put checkmarks and highlights and
stuff but you know I just hated this my
friends were out having a good time her
friends would criticize her they would
say you can't make boys stay in the
house reading books they'll grow up
they'll hate you and I would overhear
them nice a mother you know they're
right but she didn't care and but after
a while I actually began to enjoy
reading those books because we were very
poor but between the covers of those
books I could go anywhere I could be
anybody I could do anything I began to
read about people of great
accomplishment and as I read those
stories I begin to see a connecting
thread I began to see that the person
who has the most to do it you and what
happens to your life is you you make
decisions you decide how much energy you
want to put behind that decision and I
came to understand that I had control of
my own destiny and at that point I
didn't hate poverty anymore because I
knew it was only temporary
I knew I could change that it was
incredibly liberating for me made all
the difference you know the human brain
if you have an average brain
you're capable of almost anything
because of the complexity of our brains
billions and billions of neurons
hundreds of billions of interconnections
it can process more than two million
bits of information in one second it
never forgets anything you've ever seen
anything you've ever heard and you know
with something like that sitting up here
why would you ever utter the words I
can't what do you mean by think big well
each one of those letters means
something special the t is for talent
which guy gives to everybody and and
everybody has their own unique set of
talents develop those use them and let
those carry you where they will the H is
for honesty if you lead a clean and
honest life and you don't have a bunch
of skeletons in the closet it's really
hard for them to come up if you don't
put them in there and it really
uncomplicated your life quite
substantially the eye is for insight
which comes from listening the people
have already gone where you're trying to
go you know a lot of the adults in your
in your life have been through the very
things that you're going through right
now
and if you can talk to them and see what
lessons they learned maybe you don't
have to repeat the same things maybe
that will allow you to move much further
and faster than they did the N is for a
nice be nice to people because once they
get over their suspicion of are you
being nice they'll be nice to you and
you can get so much more done when
you're being nice when they're being
nice and not get caught up in the
meanness and the selfishness that is
promoted by many segments of our society
the K is for knowledge which is the the
way that you make yourself more valuable
and no one else can do that for you you
have to actively participate in the
process of becoming knowledgeable and
the mechanism for doing that is the next
letter B books you know some people say
I don't like reading books besides that
I can learn anything I need to learn
from watching DVDs and videos but it's
like saying
that you can develop your muscles by
watching somebody else love wait it no
it doesn't work that way you have to
exercise your brain if you want it to
work for you and reading is a perfect
way of doing that the second eye is for
in-depth learning learning for the sake
of knowledge and understanding as
opposed to just learning some answers so
that you can put them down on a quiz
that superficial learning doesn't last
very long and the last letter G is for
God which is such an important part of
each of us as individuals and the fabric
of our nation and we make a grave error
when we allow the secular progressive
movement to push God out of our lives
you know we shouldn't try to force God
on them but by the same token we should
not allow them to remove God from our
lives maybe some parting words for our
viewers
well my parting words would involve what
do you really want in your life what do
you want to accomplish
are you complacent and are you happy
just to be doing what you're doing or do
you think there's potentially more and
if you think there's more why not use
that tremendous brain that God gave you
in order not only to envision it but to
make it happen not only for yourself but
for those people around you
because real success involves lifting up
those or around you and making your
environment a better place than it was
before you got there
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Rachel Ally
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur you want me to profile next
leave it down in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I'd also love to
know which of Ben's top ten rules hit
you the hardest had the biggest meaning
for you leave it in the comments and I
will join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
what are you particularly gifted in do
you have any special gifts and talents
you know everybody has special gifts and
talents and I started analyzing my own
life and I said what really unusual
things have happened to you because
usually those very unusual things have
something to do with your gifts and
talents and I remembered that I became a
foosball champion in college go off to a
big prestigious Ivy League school like
Yale but I remember being a football
champion that was a great thing but that
required a tremendous amount of eye hand
coordination and I remember working one
summer at a steel factory and as a
college student
they let me operate the crane now these
cranes very complex they had a whole
bunch of levers that you had the push
and pull because you were maneuvering
these multi-ton steel packages through
very narrow aisles and stacking them on
the backs of trucks and if you made even
the slightest error you could make a
multiple thousand-dollar error and these
people trusted me having never worked
one of these things before after seeing
me play with it for just an hour or so
and I had that job for the whole summer
and I said those people must have had a
tremendous amount of confidence and me
College did who was the only college
student working at the field at the
steel factory so I started thinking I
want to do something that requires a lot
of I hand coordination and then I was
also a very careful person I never
knocked things over and said oops which
is a great characteristic for a
neurosurgeon I got a time
and I had the ability to think in three
dimensions you know most people think in
two dimensions but to think in three
dimensions be able to keep your spatial
orientation very very important if
you're in somebody's brain because it's
just like mush it's just a big pile of
mush it doesn't have a lot of structures
in it to tell you where you are so if
you can't keep in mind where all the
little nuclei and tracks and things are
all of your patients will come out
looking like that
so don't necessarily want to do that
even and then I love to dissect things I
always love to dissect things you know
when I was a kid and I would be sitting
at the table eating and I would have my
fork and my knife out dissecting out all
the little neurovascular bundles out of
the meat and putting that in a pile and
my mother would be saying you can't eat
with us you go sit on the landing but
and I always if there was a little
bugger around or a little rodent or
something that I could catch I always
knew what was inside I'd love to dissect
things so I put all that together and I
said you'd be a terrific neurosurgeon
now yeah
doesn't mean that I couldn't have been a
good dentist or a history professor or
even god forbid a lawyer but but I
probably I probably would not have been
excelling to the same degree because I
wouldn't have taken advantage of the
special gifts and talents that God
provided